the floor back to Michael just one quick
uh announcement I want to try changing
up the protocol a little bit when people
ask questions so keep all the questions
coming the discussion is wonderful just
if you have a question if you wouldn't
mind pausing for like two seconds I want
to run over to you with the microphone
so just just pause for like one or two
seconds and I'll give you the mic and I
think it'll help both capturing and for
everyone else hearing
you forget we'll deal with it but try to
just pause for like two seconds all
right
all right
um we're good so welcome back welcome
back
uh does anyone have a solution to the
puzzle
wait
you told me that there are some hand
gestures that I'm supposed to know this
is not an addiction
okay
all right all right let me I will not
give you the solution actually
let me remind you what the puzzle was
wait what
okay uh it's a crisis
ah I see it's turned off should I say
all right
do you have the solution
not just form the outer product and
that's kind of like tossing it into B
squared bins and you can just check
every one of those things
doesn't Okay uh it doesn't qualify as
fast somehow oh I see now this is the
other product yeah okay
[Laughter]
um I see I see uh well maybe maybe
because yeah it's fft
the solution is fft uh you can do it
it's a convolution what you need to do
is convolve uh convolve count sketch one
and count sketch two so you can do this
uh maybe in some quadratic way so maybe
that seems quadratic correct but you can
also do a convolution
okay good um
good so this by the way is a beautiful
uh this is a beautiful idea of palm and
uh pay and uh and palm this is known as
tensor sketch uh we will get back to it
uh
just sketch an application for this uh
formulation all right
okay so the uh the uh the question was
whether we have
for this for the sketch right so let me
first say yes I guess somehow uh I'm
thinking no uh you have
for example maybe you have some
oh
maybe these X I's encode some events
that happen I'm just making up an
application
yeah it's nice maybe the excise accounts
for how many times something happens
just it's a vector of variables random
variables and you want to know the most
correlated ones I see right the
correlated pairs yeah and you want to
just compress your variables not the
pairs and then you find the most
correlated pairs somehow uh we'll get
back to this in the context of Kernel
methods what we'll do linear algebra in
this hour and
one application will be if you're trying
to sort of say kernel regression or we
have a bunch of data points and you are
forming a kernel Matrix on them and your
kernel is the polynomial kernels
that's what you do all right we will
learn how to solve this kernel image
regression using technique space we have
this nature and we'll use this
particular ly great great question
good okay uh good so the answer is uh
fft and we will will spell out the
convolution in more detail later so I
won't do well enough now remains a
puzzle for a while uh good so now coming
back to a question that was asked before
about the
typical distribution of X I's uh right
in real life what do the lectures that
we want to take top K elements off look
like uh
so as I mentioned this is the guarantee
that Camel sketch gives and it gives it
for worst case X
those are really cool results of
Maintenance price from soda 14. and it
shows the following but if x actually is
drawn from some distribution and it's a
nice distribution like Paul or should
pin then the Precision of count sketch
itself is significantly better and
although this is a nice result where you
know the author's given a very refined
analysis of the error estimates it's not
just the basic medium taking and
variances that we do but that's that's
beautiful uh the soda for team paper
assumes purely independent hashing so
for the analysis that I gave uh two ways
of dependence is enough uh the solar 14
paper assumes purely independent hashing
so that was a deficiency the very recent
work I guess is the upcoming work of uh
uh
David
gives a pseudorandom generator that can
be used to
remove the Assumption of pure
independent hashing from limiting price
work so it's an active area very cool
okay
ah one
interesting or one question that I find
very interesting is
the measurement complexity of count
sketch that I stated as optimal
asymptotically right but can we get none
as I'm talking about in particular
note that
works on sparse recovery that go through
the alone minimization round around
their non-sub-linear they actually get
very good constants whereas if we were
to make count sketch sublinear time
decodable the constants would not be
that great for example I didn't cover
how you decoded in sublinear time but
roughly the way you do this is
you well if you set up a data structure
you'll take your k
your Universe you hash into
10K buckets and then you look at the
buckets you know by some basic Market
bound that most of your top K elements
will be isolated in the markets and for
those isolated people you can figure out
what they are and you can get good
estimates of them then you can subtract
bilinearity of the sketch and you can
recurse on what remains so what remains
you hash into more buckets etc etc
okay so that at some basic level reminds
me of constructions of ldpc codes where
it is very important that the Tanner
graph which is this bipartite graph that
tells us which element contributes to
which bucket so to speak
if we were to achieve capacity the
tenant graph actually should not be
regular and these Tanner graphs are very
carefully optimized to achieve capacity
and the peeling decoders uh well don't
lose constants I wonder if something
like this can be done for account sketch
related questions there are some very
nice recent works that go in this
direction so for example
a solo paper of Stephen waltzer on
appealing close to the orientability of
thresholds so this is getting a good
constant very cool paper
um simple set sketching by Erasmus pay
Stefan balzer and cothers and Sosa this
year it doesn't get optimal bounds but
it gets very nice constants as it
happens to be simple
okay
is there any link to in this field to a
compressive sensing oh good uh yes
definitely
good so the L1 minimization that I
mentioned is compressive sensing uh the
uh the results that we obtained are also
compressive sensing we can't sketch
results the ones I mentioned the L
Infinity to L2 sparse recovery guarantee
that is compressive Samsung
[Music]
um
period
what the spell okay what does L1
minimization mean ah good uh L1
minimization is uh basically a technique
pioneered by Candace and Tau for com
sparse recovery compressed sensing the
question is basically the following uh
you have a vector X it is approximately
sparse you want to recover it from uh
linear measurements from some a times x
all right and how you do this is you
take your a times x you have you know
the right hand side and basically what
you would like to do is try all the
sparse lectures and check which one fits
your measurements the best but that's
hard you don't know how to optimize over
sparse vectors instead what you do is
you add a minimizer add an objective
function to add a turn to your objective
function that asks to minimize the L1
Norm
of your vector as opposed to l0 which is
the number of non-zeros this becomes
tractable
and gets nice constants Etc
so it's very interesting to sort of get
the best of both worlds we have
techniques that are sublinear time that
don't require the solution of a big
linear system so here to to find the
solution you solve an LP
uh and in particular the entire universe
is involved it's very expensive uh but
it would be very cool to do both
all right
I think I think I know I was debating
debating about the expensiveness of
solving sometimes yeah
and you at some point necessarily now
but uh you're saying that you would be
nice to get some some kind of can you
state sort of a formal version of that
at some point let me state it right now
uh I want a sublinear Time sparse
recovery primitive uh that uh has very
good constants in the measurement
complexity
or anything hybrid
a weaker objective take L1 minimization
which requires the solution of linear
system uh linear program linear linear
program yes
but uh maybe marry it a little bit
with the sparse recovery with these
randomized hashing techniques it's
exactly when you're saying
it's expensive you mean just like not
sub linear like yes exactly extensive is
an awesome linear but it's expensive in
practice sometimes but the universe is
big
yeah more questions or
yeah I guess in the in the compressive
sensing World they sometimes assume
a distribution of the inputs
right I mean if you if you if you it's
it they probably make an assumption
that's akin to but maybe stronger than
your assumption that the K A Heavy
Hitters uh amount to a significant
fraction I mean if you significantly
strengthened
uh that assumption maybe you could get
away with because they have methods for
avoiding
linear programming or or you know full
full strength linear programming they
use uh simpler methods that work only
under an assumption about the input so
that might be an interesting Direction
no yeah I don't actually know which ones
you mean here that sounds interesting
I'll try to find a reference talk more
it's been years more uh yes yeah it's a
good question
okay great
um
uh so a couple a couple of other notes
uh on uh on on sound sketch
one important thing to note is that
the
the techniques that we
ah yeah so first uh of course we were
choosing the hash function uniformly at
random and the sine function uniformly
at random but it is possible to learn
them so there's a whole field of
learning augmented uh sketching and
learning augmented algorithm design do
come to our Workshop later in the
program to find out the details right
another important thing to note is that
the analysis that we have seen is very
much not adversarially robust so the way
this works is we fix the stream up front
we fix the queries up front and then we
argue that with high probability over
the
um over the randomness of the data
structure the estimates will be good uh
What happens if the input is chosen by
an adversary that has partial knowledge
of the data structure so that's there
has been a lot of exciting work on this
so this is the necessarily robust
sketching world again I'll come to the
workshop to learn a lot more on this
well you should note that in general
these are based data structures so it
feels like another three if the
adversary knows the hashing the other so
you can force a collision and it will
it's definitely very non-trivial but
there are methods yes so when you say he
has partial knowledge does that mean he
just knows the answer to some queries or
any other kind of good uh I I was
purposefully
my partial knowledge I mean generally I
mean that the adversary has been
interacting with the data structure
right so the other side yeah it has seen
some answers based on the previous
answers decides the next query
Etc
yeah
yes exactly
yes uh good uh so there are exciting
works on this so for instance a very
nice recent work of uh Edith poems
Nelson and others on the uh robustness
of making count sketch robust to
Adaptive uh
good
um
okay uh fantastic so we have seen count
sketch
um
before we move on to Applications of
count sketch and various dimensionality
reduction techniques in linear algebra
let's pause for a second and look at the
cam sketch Matrix and note some
interesting facts about it so here's
what the count sketch Matrix looks like
remember that we're talking about
sketching right so we're acting on our
input which is a vector X and the Heavy
Hitters example it's the frequency
vector by a matrix on the left so what
does Discount sketch Matrix look look
like well here is roughly what it looks
like the property is that it's a hashing
Matrix with random signs so every column
of this Matrix contains exactly one
non-zero and this has a plus one or a
minus one right so every uh
um
that's when you hash into just be
buckets once count sketch of course
repeats this many times but that's just
one repetition all right if you look at
a given row well the known zeros are in
the places that correspond to items that
hash to that bucket or wonderful
so in general we we put random plus
minus ones or gaussians if we like on
random subsets of the universe
note that applying the count sketch
Matrix to vectors really fast
because there's exactly one non-zero in
every column you can compute s times x
for any X in time proportional to the
number of non-zeros in x
it's very interesting this will be
useful later
so this is just to point out that allows
non-zeros correspond to buckets
um all right so here see accounts get
just random restrictions and then puts
random signs uh on the non-zero faces
what if we don't do random signs or if
we just look at a matrix that takes dot
products of the input Vector with random
subsets of the universe without doing
random signs what do we learn from the
distribution of from s times x for this
Matrix
uh the answer is that we can learn the
l0 norm of the input the number of
non-zeros so that's how distinct
elements sketches that approximate the
number of distinct elements in a stream
work right and really what you do is so
here for example I have a matrix where
the first row can contains a very sparse
sample of the universe it's just two
ones in random locations the next row
contains three ones the next one and one
five ones etc etc so they get denser so
of course if you have a x that has a
certain number of non-zeros You observe
this Matrix times x and then you just
check
which role is non-zero and this gives
you information about how many non-zeros
you had
good
um
all right what if you don't do random
restrictions and just put random sign
everywhere then you get the Johnson
language transfer
instead of random signs you could also
put a gaussians of appropriate variants
so for example if you if your sketching
Matrix is just a single row of IID
gaussians then it preserves the L2
squared Norm of your vector and
expectation by the two stability of
gaussians if you take M rows of IAD
gaussians of appropriately scaled down
variance then this will actually
preserve L2 Norm L2 Norms with high
probability and high is
exponentially high in the number of rows
okay uh so such matrices though have the
downside and the downside is that it's
difficult to computationally expensive
to compute s times
um one other thing that I would like to
note is
the the Johnson industrial transform
itself can be sped up for example by
using the hadamark transform uh so
something known as the subsampled
hannamar transform is a sketching Matrix
that also lets us approximate the
euclidean norm of the input Vector The
Matrix is a nicely factorizable as P
times H times D where D is the diagonal
random sine Matrix
H is the hardware transform and P is
just a sampling Matrix so the statement
here is that if you take any Vector you
randomize the signs and then take the
Hanuman transform the energy of the
resulting Vector is pretty equally
spread across coordinates so if you want
to approximate it you might as well just
sample in a few places
uh
the advantage is of course that
s times x can be computed fast using the
fast Fourier transform fast Hardware
transform
close to the n and Z of
the time though so this
if the input is sparse there's no
advantage
the frequency moment the question so we
have seen the Johnson Linden Styles
transform that approximates the L2
squared Norm of a vector which is if the
vector is the frequency Vector of a
stream then that's just the sum of
squared frequencies this is known as the
second frequency moment
um if we instead do random restrictions
but not the random signs then we learn
the l0 more of the vector the number of
non-zeros and in general one can ask
this a question this was asked by Alan
Matthias and zebede what is the
complexity the space complexity of
approximating the P frequency moment in
a data stream and it turns out that for
any P between 0 and 2 we have seen 0 and
2 the end points one can approximate in
poly logarithmic space pu larger than
that requires a polynomial amount of
space and the size of the universe
and this of course has led to amazing uh
lower bound techniques for example the
optimal bound is from bar yourself and
others this information Theory
information complexity approach to data
streaming lower clouds okay
uh good so
that's all I wanted to say about the
classical applications to data streaming
so let me now move to
linear algebra
okay
excellent so
we switch gears and we asked ourselves
the following question
so those that I'm given n High
dimensional data points
but A1 A2 through a n so they live in Rd
and a bunch of values
BJ
you should think of these values as the
evaluation of some function on these
data okay so here's a not very high
dimensional example here this is one
dimensional actually two-dimensional
pointers
augmented with a constant term right
I have a bunch of points and
measurements of some function and I want
to find a good least squares fit so
that's the linear regression problem
um
formally the least squares problem is
I want to minimize the sum of squared
deviations of my linear function the
coefficients are given by X on the
samples AJ and the True Values the ones
that I want to fit are BJ
good
I might want to also regularize the
problem uh by adding an L2 squared
constraint with some parameter Lambda
that's a regularization term
s
is an index J with x
ah good question I did not
so Michael's question was whether I
missed an index J with X and I mean it
because I'm thinking that the ajs are
row vectors
the dot of length D and this is the dot
product Oh So if I missed anything then
this would be the DOT
no they're all vectors no transfers
okay and X is a column
oh sure sure is the confirmation okay so
the ajs are a rows of a matrix a and X
is a column Vector so AJ times x is just
the dot product
excellent okay so think of n the number
of rows in this Matrix as being very big
and much bigger than D the
dimensionality of our vectors
this was the big data regime imagine you
have lots of noisy samples and you want
to solve this fast
any questions about the setting
good so over constrained at least
squares regression maybe with a
regularization term
good so some amount of linear algebra
tells us that the solution is this
all right so some kind of inverse of a
transpose a appropriately regularized
times a a transpose B so if we were to
solve this naively uh with classical
techniques then this would be n times D
Squared time linear in the large
dimension of quadratic in the small
maybe we can do a bit faster with fast
matrix multiplication but this is not
our concern here what we would like to
do instead is
is get a linear nearly linear time
algorithm in the size of a assuming that
the size of a is significantly bigger
than uh bigger than poly d
so I'm interested in an algorithm that
has
size of a plus poly D and maybe some
precision
thanks
good so I don't know how to do this
exactly so I will be shooting for
approximate solutions to the least
squares problem
what's an approximate solution to a
least squares a problem I will want to
OnePlus Epsilon approximate the
objective value
so basically it's a one plus Epsilon
approximate the quality of fit
right I could ask to find a solution X
Prime that is coefficient X Prime that
are close to X star but that's not
really possible my Matrix could be
ill-conditioned it's difficult and maybe
even not so interesting so instead I
just want some X Prime such that the
quality of fit under X Prime is pretty
much the same as the quality of fit
under the optimal X star
okay
excellent now uh
given that this is a sketching talk
the way I will
achieve the goal is by designing a
sketch that reduces the number of rows
in a
to something manageable so we'll want to
squish The Matrix a to something with
polynomial in D and this Precision
parameter Epsilon a number of rows
similarly of course we need to squish B
and then we'll get a smaller problem uh
we'll solve it exactly using classical
techniques and quality
time and it will be great
so what we want to make sure though is
that the squishing of the of the problem
needs to happen in time
linear to a linear in the size of a
okay
so that's the idea
I'll design some sketching Matrix and
the sketch Matrix will just be the count
sketch Matrix
um
instead of solving ax minus b l two Norm
squared plus a Lambda equation Norm of X
I'll just
exactly solve the dimensionality to
reduce the problem
here's a pictorial representation of
this
this is my sketchy Matrix it reduces M
to something manageable so note that the
ultimate number of rows will be will be
bigger than D it'll be D Squared or so
so that's the reduced row
okay
any questions about the setup and what
we want to achieve
ment
inside
oh great so the question was the
question was
um when I say linear in the
size of the Matrix a runtime what do I
mean do I mean n times d
or do I mean the number of non-zeros I
mean the number of non-zeros
yeah great great question
so quick question so how what should I
think of a Lambda because if Lambda is
large The Matrix is well conditioned
then I could just use some iterative
methods right excellent
um the question was what should I think
of Lambda
for now think of Lambda as zero and
later we'll see what to do with the
general Lambda for large Lambda is the
problem will indeed get easier yeah
great point
foreign
good so this is our goal
uh fantastic so
we want some kind of a dimensionality
reduction primitive that can squish
linear regression problems so what
property is of a sketching Matrix S
would suffice for this purpose
so I claim that the answer to this is
the following uh let me Define the
notion of Subspace embeddings
what's a Subspace embedding
a random Matrix S I think the count
sketch Matrix is a d Epsilon Delta
Subspace embedding
if the following is true
let's fix our favorite Subspace p in
this n-dimensional euclidean space
fix now think of your favorite Subspace
p it's a Subspace of Dimension d
s is a Subspace embedding if the
following is true
think of your Subspace you flip the
coins to determine the sketching Matrix
S
and then you look at every Vector Y in
your Subspace
if you measure its euclidean Norm
then you squish it down using your
sketch and measure the euclidean norm of
the squished vector these have to be the
same
for all vectors why
simultaneously
so Subspace embedding is a random Matrix
that with high probability approximately
preserves the geometry of Any Given
Subspace
because I think this is kind of related
to Johnson Linden's child's transforms
in the jail uh the JL Lemma it basically
take
you want to preserve distances between
points and this amounts to preserving
lengths of vectors that are differences
between points
so the jail Johnson Linden Strauss is
basically sort of a one-dimensional
Subspace embedding of source
correct whereas here this is a higher
dimensional version you need to preserve
geometry of the entire Subspace
obtuse on one plus minus Epsilon
Distortion Force
just a technical question so this is a
probability where Y is chosen
uh no it's probability over s great yeah
okay yeah so very important uh to note
the quantification yeah it's with high
probability over s
something is good for all y
simultaneously yeah so but I don't
understand it for all y that belongs to
P but then you say it's for every P so
ah why isn't it for every why ah no no
good it's for for every P comes before
the probability so that's what I'm
saying think of your favorite p
for any fixed p with high probability
over s
good things happen for all y's NP
you don't get to choose P after
observing s
I guess there's a subtle linguistic
difference between for every and for all
right so so yeah so basically the
quantification of p over p is not after
not after s is this help
no also I still don't understand why it
doesn't mean that it's not for every why
oh it's not for every why because if how
would you establish that it's for every
y one way to do this would be to say oh
I'll take a union bound over all P's for
instance well you can't because if you
were to do a union bound this will start
multiplying this failure probability
all right
no no great so the distribution is not a
function yeah because the distribution
appears before P yes yes the
distribution is not a function of P
uh and uh we want something to hold for
a fairly fixed
uh very fixed p
yes this is
application is that somehow if you put
every substance after this it's kind of
conscious
the Subspace is before the probability
correct so basically you fix your
favorite subsequence
then you toss the coins to determine s
and S has to work for that assumption
so say it's the same thing that we did
with count schedule
right now I said for every X with high
probability over the randomness of
account sketch we will be able to
recover
something about X
this doesn't mean that there will not
exist in different effects approaches
Matrix
very connected do my job connecting the
top so to connect it against the
structural sparsification
this is asking for a distribution over s
such that then for any Subspace P if we
looked at s transpose that's restricted
to P it's a special sparsifier of the
IPR approximation
yeah that's right yes maybe let me do a
quick example that's relevant to what we
do later it will be useful
yeah
so it's an example of a Subspace P
rather let me give you a
collection of subspaces P
um
so what I'm going to do is I'll choose a
subset R of coordinates
of size d
you know I'm interested in vectors in RN
n is way bigger than D and let me pick
my favorite sub subset R of coordinates
okay and then I let P sub I'll let P sub
r
sub R will be the set of all vectors in
RN
P sub R be the set of all vectors in RN
that are 0 except on coordinates in r
it's a coordinate Subspace
then
let me instantiate count sketch
right so what's the what's the count
sketch Matrix
I'll choose the counts cache Matrix as
you know this Matrix that takes
uh n dimensional vectors and squishes
them down to let's say 100 D Squared
coordinates
so this will be a matrix with a hundred
D Squared rows
and N columns and every row will be a
plus minus one in a random place
thank you
okay
now I claim
um I claim maybe on this board
I claim that for any fixed
r
um
unless I messed up my arithmetic okay I
said 100 D Squared rows so I'll
yeah so here's what I claim I claim that
for any fixed r
ated
ah
foreign
to that board as well
should I switch that to black as well
not anymore okay future for any fixed r
ather the phones
advice
okay
this is what I call
for any fixed r
I claim that actually for this
particular
instance this is true with Epsilon
equals zero
like that the count sketch Matrix on any
fixed sub fixed coordinate Subspace is
an isometry
with high constant probability as long
as you count sketch into D Squared times
a constant bucket
why uh because there are no collisions
by the birthday Paradox uh right there
will be no collisions so if you take a
vector whose non-zeros live in a fixed
set of D coordinates what does counts
cage do it just hashes things into
buckets but with high probability there
will be no collisions between your
coordinates
so Norms are preserved
on the other hand
once you see the Matrix of course you
can find some other r
for which this will not work right
because out of n coordinates if I hash
into D Squared buckets there will be a
ton of collisions so you just pick two
I'm saying all right here's another
isometry not only will it not be an
isometry it will not be a Subspace
embedding at all it'll simply lose rank
thank you
all right cool no this is actually
perfect thanks a lot for the question
because what we're going to do this is a
wonderful model for the actual proof
right what will prove is you know
literally that this works not just for
any fixed coordinate Subspace but
actually the same statement is true for
every Subspace
and instead of arguing about whether
there are collisions between discrete
objects we'll need to argue about
framinous Norm distances between
matrices not okay
cool are there any other questions this
was wonderful
so I really like to think of
so I would like to talk
I really like to think of sparse
recovery where we have like a sparse
signal and then you hit it with some
Matrix and then you try to recover the
signal so basically like this is kind of
like a perfect RIT Matrix from that
point of view only that you have like
large you you basically
you just like have to pay more in like
in the sketch signal right
uh
Maybe
let's yeah I don't immediately see the
yeah so there's so some some sort of a
for each version of rip let's take this
offline yeah okay
all right sounds good so okay so we got
the quantifiers right so that's a
wonderful uh so let's look at some
examples of Subspace embeddings
about identity map was a Subspace
embedding doesn't do anything preserves
uh norms
if you take s to be a matrix with
about D by Epsilon squared independent
gaussians it'll preserve it'll be a
Subspace synthetic uh by an Epsilon net
plus Union Bond argument
uh you can also prove similar properties
for subsample randomized how to mod
transform uh it's non-trivial but you
can't
um example four is our example count
sketch where we're going to prove this
now
and there are others
okay
so first why are before I prove that
count sketch is a Subspace embedding and
for which we already have a pretty good
model uh to be honest
um
why
are Subspace embeddings useful
so let's just convince ourselves that if
satisfies the Subspace embedding
property then instead of solving the big
linear least squares regression problem
you might as well solve the small one
and it will not change the quality of
fit much
all right
okay so let's let's take s let's take s
to be a d plus one Epsilon a small
constant Subspace embedding
what's the Subspace that we're
interested in
well
what's the least squares regression
problem
the act of solving the least squares
regression problem is the act of finding
a recombination of columns of a that
match B best
so all Such recombinations live in the
column span of the Matrix a with a B
Vector attached to it so that will be
our Subspace p
now by the Subspace embedding property
for every candidate solution x that you
pick
if you look at the euclidean norm of ax
minus B
and compare it to the euclidean norm of
s a x minus s b they're pretty much the
same
multiplicatively up to someone plus
minus Epsilon
good
and
and now we're done
because suppose that X Prime
uh it should be already clear that this
is good but let's do the sequence of
inequalities anyway remember X Prime was
the minimizer of the reduced least
scores regression problem
so the quality and we're interested in
the quality of fit that X Prime gives
for the big original problem
so this quality of fit is up to some
plus minus Epsilon loss
equal to the quality of fit
with that X Prime provides for the
reduced problem
now X Prime is optimal for the reduced
problem so that's at most what x star
the optimum for the original problem
gives
for the reduced problem
but that by the Subspace embedding
property is pretty much the same as the
quality of fit that X star gives
for the original problem
okay
so Subspace embeddings are useful
fantastic
so now we'll prove the following theorem
this is originally due to Clarkson and
Woodruff the proof that we'll see is
from a paper of avron on grian and
Woodruff it's a cleaner proof
simpler
we'll show that count sketch with B
buckets is a d Epsilon order D Squared
by Epsilon squared B Subspace embedding
all right so that's a bit of a bit of an
expression there so let me unpack it for
you now what do we really want to have
in the third parameter third parameter
is the failure probability
all right so what we want is the failure
probability to be small let's say
smaller than a small constant so we want
D Squared over Epsilon squared B to be
smaller than 1 over 100 let's say so
this just means that as long as you
count
yes
so we want D Squared over Epsilon
squared B to be at most 1 over 100 say
so this just means that we should be
count sketching into at least
D Squared by Epsilon squared buckets as
long as we do that
so it's basically a extension of what we
did here
we know that even if you think of just
coordinate subspaces then you need D
Squared buckets
there you're either an isometry or
another Subspace embedding at all so
absolute there is no Epsilon and here
we're saying that for any Epsilon D
Squared by Epsilon squared minus also
fine
good
so that's our Matrix it can be applied
in n and Z of a time which is excellent
and it will squish the number of rows in
a down to D Squared by Epsilon Epsilon
squared
then we get a smaller least squares
regression problem we solve it exactly
by the standards
okay
so let's prove it
so that's what we
um so we would like to prove the
Subspace emitting property
far
we'll prove it for the column span of a
for some notational reasons
because why not
um
well the proof goes through for any any
p uh let U be an orthonormal basis for
our Subspace
we remember we cared about an
orthonormal basis for the column span of
a with the vector B attached I'll just
call it the column span of a to simplify
things so that's the corresponding
expression cool so
we want that with high probability over
X the sketch the Norms of all vectors in
our Subspace are preserved up to some
Epsilon loss
so now all vectors in our Subspace can
be written as U times y
where Y is some Vector of coefficients
in RDM oh it's a d dimensional Subspace
uses its basis so we all we want is that
for all Y in Rd
s-u-y L2 Norm squared minus L2 Norm of y
is at most Epsilon times L2 Norm of Y
so used here that L2 Norm of U times Y
is actually the same as L2 Norm of Y
because U is an orthonormal basis
very nice so again this is the pictorial
representation our substrace is a
example
I've lost track so uh for all Y in Rd so
where does your Subspace excellent come
in
um so the Subspace Subspace was called P
but now we have an orthonormal basis for
it we call that basis U
so
our Subspace p is the set of vector set
of vectors U times Y where Y is any
Vector in Rd
as the Matrix U
is an N by D Matrix with alternate
orthonormal columns
so now in general in the Subspace
embedding property we want to compare
the norm of U times y squared to the
norm of s u times y
you take the norm of your vector minus
the norm of the sketched version of your
vector but since U is an orthonormal
Matrix Norm of U times Y is actually the
norm of Y
squared
yeah perfect so this is a step missed
here and that's great thanks yeah so
that that's that's why we have
excellent
oh it's a picture that goes along with
this
um
aha
all right so we need to
prove that s u y euclidean Norm squared
is close to equilion moment of Y squared
we want to express this as the quadratic
form of some Matrix
so let's let's write the euclidean log
squared as
including Norm squared of something is
that something transpose itself
so euclidean Norm square root of s u y
is the transpose of that
times that
similarly euclidean normal Y is y
transpose why
now we can pull out the Y on both sides
and we realize that this is y transpose
some Matrix y so it's a quadratic Norm
of a quadratic form of some Matrix at y
all right what is that Matrix let's
design some words for it that we can use
well basically we have this what is s
times u u is an orthonormal basis for
our Subspace
s times U and U is orthonormal if you
form the gram Matrix of u u transpose U
you'll get the identity
now what we do is we say all right we
apply the sketch on all the vectors in
our orthonormal basis and form the gram
Matrix again
right so this is the gram Matrix of the
sketched basis minus the gram Matrix of
the original basis
and you know uh the grand Matrix of the
original basis was identity and the hope
is that after sketching is so close to
Identity
but now formally what we need to prove
is that
the
gram Matrix of the sketched basis
is close to the identity and spectral
Norm because we want that for every y
the quadratic form at of this Matrix at
y is at most Epsilon times the L2
squared Norm of Y
so it's an operator Norm it's an
operator Norm bound
sorry but I'm just confused so U
transpose U U would have been the gram
at n or would have been a d by D gram
Matrix exactly uh after the sketching we
want is the same
yeah great point right so you see you
have D you had D vectors you still have
D vectors it's just that the vectors are
a bit distorted they now live in a lower
dimensional space
they were n-dimensional now they're I
see it yeah okay okay
stocks this is asking that you trans
Pros s transpose Su is a special
approximation of the identity exactly
yes yes
okay
um fantastic so we want to prove this
um
I want to prove that this happens with
high constant probability as long as the
number of buckets that we hash into is
at least D Squared by Epsilon squared
um okay uh in sushant's talk a similar
bounds were obtained by applying the
Matrix Bernstein inequality
right
so
here it turns out to be more beneficial
to sort of go more directly why because
actually a stronger bound holds uh well
instead of proving the operator Norm
bound will just prove that the same
bound holds with high probability for
the in the forbidness norm
of every Matrix upper bounds the
spectral Norm February Matrix so the
result will follow
the frobenius norm is a simpler Beast to
work with than a spectral bar you can
start just comparing nature system
entry-wise right and that will really
power the uh Power what we do okay so
we'll put the stronger bound we'll show
that the with high constant probability
of the square tribinous Norm is at most
Epsilon squared cool
okay so what is this about uh
now we're comparing
we're comparing the gram Matrix
of our basis U
let's see
to the gram Matrix of the sketched
version of this basis
ah
what is the gram Matrix the grand Matrix
of D vectors
is just a matrix of dot products
g i j is UI transpose u j
all right and that's sort of G and G
Prime that we're interested in is the
same thing but
we should be looking at sketched
the dot products between sketched
columns
and we're interested in the forbinius
norm squared of the difference between
these two matrices
um that's just the sum over all the D
Squared entries of the squared distance
in the Square distance difference of the
corresponding entry
right so we're really just interested in
in the sum overall I comma J in D
of U I transpose u j minus
sketched UI count sketched UI transpose
counts cached UJ
squared
so now this is
the separates over all coordinates
just taking my intuition with the Norms
the moment we wrote for benius is the
goal we kind of
increase the number of rows we need in a
Subspace embedding to probably but like
we probably now need at least like a D
Squared or something like before that we
maybe had hope
hope of something better
came to Target like we need something
super linear
for some space embedding to work
yes I agree that um yeah well I would
think about a difference right that you
know we're trying to prove a special one
bound uh but we realize that somehow the
tight setting basically how can the yeah
we just realized that in the tight
setting of the spectral one bomb fails
the for being used compound Fields as
well
right so this is the situation in which
there isn't really you know the type in
the tight settings there isn't really a
factory detail s
basically if you look at all the
eigenvalues
basically
another way suppose we want we are
defined like Subspace embeddings as
wanting this for BDS guarantee oh then
I'm saying that we couldn't have hoped
better than my
like
leave the OnePlus Delta okay if we were
to just connect it straight away
okay so uh basically now it's clear that
what we need to understand is I have two
lectures UI and u j
how is the dog product between them
related to the dove product between
count sketched versions of the two
vectors and that's what we will
understand now let me just do the
intuition for how they are related and I
think we need to adjourn after that
so this entire statement is the
statement
that hashing with randomscience
preserves a DOT product
so let's pick two vectors X and Y and RD
we want to prove that
X transpose counts case to Y is roughly
X transpose y
and here's a pictorial representation of
this say my vectors here are in
dimension eight so here's X1 X2 X3 X8
and Y 1 through Y8
um I'm interested in the dot how the dot
product between the two relates to the
dot product between the hashed versions
Let's do an example
fix a hash function write out and
options
okay so here is the sketched X
for this particular hash function the
hash function is of course the same on
the left and on the right it's the same
Constitution so the first entry
corresponds to the first bucket first
bucket contains X4 there is no Collision
there so it's perfect sine of 4 times X4
the second bucket sine of eight times X8
the third bucket has a collision it has
X1 and X6 so there's S1 times X1 plus S6
plus times X6
and similarly for y
um fantastic
now let's write out what the dot product
is between X and Y we know that it's x
one y one plus X2 Y2 x 8 y 8. now what's
the dot product between the hashes
let's let's do it
we go over all the hash buckets
the first hashback it contains S4 X4
times s4y4
so that seems really good there's no
Collision here that's perfect you just
get a turn that we wanted second bucket
is similar just contains X8 Y8 the third
bucket has a collision so we so we get
something a little bit funkier ideally
here we would like to get X1 y1 plus X6
Y6 because 1 and 6 hash there but we'll
get some cross terms they will be
annoying but we'll deal with and the
same for the last two buckets
okay
good so let's just simplify this if you
look at the first bucket well S4 is plus
minus one S4 squared is one great same
with S8 okay here let's just separate
out the terms that we want and the terms
that we don't want
so we get X1 y1 x x y 6 plus the cross
terms product of science times X1 Y6 so
y1 X6 and the same for the blaster
all right so overall
uh in general the following is true
pictures is the actual dot product plus
the cross terms that come from
coordinates colliding distinct
coordinates colliding in a bucket some
over all buckets some over all I comma J
distinct with hash into that bucket s i
j s i s j x y x x i uh YG
uh it's immediate that it's an unbiased
estimator by what we did before and just
take the expectations
um and now we adjourn and we'll do the
variance once we get back uh now the
plan for the rest is we'll do we'll
analyze count sketch we'll prove it's a
Subspace embedding I will then talk
about
about the tensorized versions of this so
kernel matrices and then I will switch
to graph sketching so we'll see how to
do connectivity in Dynamic streams using
by sketching The Edge vertex incidence
Matrix that was a huge object to the
discussion and social talk and finally
how to do spectral approximations
good
[Applause]
I guess you did the D Square because it
tensorizes better or or as opposed to
the D over Epsilon Square
oh so say again I mean so you you can
get better Subspace and the dimension
right oh oh good so the dimension you do
you can get uh closer yeah that's good
all right uh but uh for that you
shouldn't be doing one round of hashing
but if you want sort of this energy of a
uh application time for your sketch if
you want it very fast ah okay yeah so
then you should be hashing the best
thing we know is just hashing you hash
once but then you run into birthday
Paradox style issues it's possible to
alleviate them uh this is called osnap
by Jelani uh care gelani Nelson and
Daniel Kane and the follow-ups
um
this basically hashes with more times
and the target Dimension gets closer to
linear but here we're analyzing the hash
once primitive and there because of the
birthday Paradox those examples the
truth is D Squared so apart from the
faster running time are there uh sort of
sketch are there other advantages
when you
kind of like do the tensor version of
this this oh oh oh I see the tensor
version of this has not really come up
uh the way it will come up is the
following if you're then interested in
kernel methods basically think of you
have these data points and then you're
not interested in their direct linear
gram Matrix but you're interested in
first constructing some feature
embedding and then doing the grand
Matrix there we will need tensorized
versions
so it shouldn't be clear how tensorized
versions at this point are not obviously
useful
can you use some of those techniques to
solve problem something like you have n
by n Matrix and you want to do a linear
regression by you but you only want your
solution to be case bars
I want to linear regression
subject to sparsity constraint
I do not know
okay
yeah that's a compressive sensing kind
of question
I'm more like lasso
your opinion yeah it's not clear because
you can't preserve L1 norms
yeah I think Misha is asking if you're
asking about you actually have a big
Matrix there's a lasso you can press
sensing is you know you have a nice
Matrix with a few rows like rip Matrix
right and then you then you optimize the
quality of Fit Plus an L1 penalty right
but I think Misha is asking you want
linear regressions we have a big Matrix
all right I agree
I agree
oh yes yes yeah you're right
yes
uh yeah I don't know if one can do
sketches
hi and one related question do you know
horse files mattress as could be how
sparse The Matrix S could be
uh
the conscience seems to be as far as it
gets right for every uh for every column
there's one non-zero so if there's any
Sporter than that then some columns have
to be zero and it's a problem
could be achievable you see such metrics
oh yes yes so oh snap oh snap lets you
do this right and if you have more
non-zeroes per column than the sketching
Dimension goes down
basically you don't run into birthday
paradoxes as much
citation correction
oh all right
please ask the experts
oh good so as Moses points out uh osnap
is uh jilani and who is as opposed to my
and previously incorrect uh citation so
please ask the experts in the audience
about everything related to oh snap okay
that's the better
any more questions
all right let's thank Michael again
[Applause]
we have a lunch break now until two
o'clock and I'll see you all then
Maybe